Horror movies are all about pushing boundaries,
taking audiences and ratings boards to the
very limit of what they can stomach.
Some films have been so hardcore that entire
countries have taken steps to ban them from
their theaters, in some cases making screening
or possessing them a criminal act.
Sometimes you can see the rationale behind
a movie being banned, but not always.
For one reason or another, these horror films
were all battlegrounds for censorship, deemed
too disturbing for viewers… but they still
managed to find their audiences anyway.
A Serbian Film
A Serbian Film has a reputation as one of
the most extreme horror movies ever made,
and it's a reputation that's well-earned.
Centering on an adult film actor who's been
hired to participate in an increasingly sadistic
production, the story is meant to be a metaphor
for life in Serbia, conveying how the country
screws its people over from birth.
That metaphor gets very literal, being represented
on screen by torture, murder, necrophilia,
and other, even worse things.
With that kind of taboo content, it's far
from surprising that a large number of countries
wanted nothing to do with the movie.
At one point or another, A Serbian Film was
banned in Germany, Norway, Brazil, Australia,
New Zealand, Malaysia, Spain, and Singapore,
and the countries that eventually allowed
the movie required significant edits.
The movie is so extreme that it's almost gotten
people thrown in real-life prison.
Following A Serbian Film's ban in Spain, the
director of a film festival faced criminal
charges for daring to show the movie anyway,
a move which drew condemnation from the film's
director.
Despite how violent the film is, it uses its
extreme violence to make a point, and of course,
no children were actually harmed during the
making of it.
A Serbian Film may be one of the most boundary-pushing
movies ever made, but it's still just a movie,
and as a horror movie, it's pretty genuinely
effective.
Saw VI & Saw 3D
The Saw series of horror movies was sadistic
from the start, but weirdly, it wasn't until
the sixth entry that any country made moves
to ban them.
For some reason, Saw VI was initially banned
from Thailand and Spain, with Spanish regulators
giving the film a rating usually reserved
for pornography.
It's an odd move, considering the sixth movie
doesn't do anything the previous five didn't
already get away with.
The follow-up picture, alternatively called
Saw 3D, Saw 7, or Saw: The Final Chapter,
was also banned from public exhibition in
Germany for its violence.
But what makes that movie more violent than
the installments that preceded it is a mystery.
The seventh Saw movie was kind of a cornball
gimmicky sequel lousy enough to put the franchise
into hibernation for years.
Hostel & Hostel: Part II
Lots of European commentators had an issue
with the first Hostel for making the continent
seem like a lethal tourist trap.
But it was only in Ukraine that the movie
pushed enough buttons to get itself banned.
Both Hostel and its sequel were outlawed in
the country for excessive cruelty, as well
as for portraying the neighborhood as a place
where tourists get tortured for money.
Despite the ban, the movie is still legally
available for private viewing, just don't
let them catch you screening it in the front
yard.
Beyond Ukraine, the uncut version of Hostel:
Part II is banned in Germany and New Zealand,
and the film was only released in Malaysia
and Singapore after undergoing cuts to its
more extreme scenes.
Some politicians in the U.K. have also argued
that the film should be illegal, a crusade
made extra absurd by the fact that at least
one politician who spoke out against the movie
eventually admitted that he'd never even watched
it.
It's a fact that speaks to how arbitrary these
censorship measures often are, one viewer's
trash is another audience's trashy good time.
Possession
Possession is one of the best and most bonkers
horror movies ever made, but that doesn't
mean everyone was comfortable with its content
when it was released in 1981.
Following a limited theatrical run in the
U.K., Possession was labeled as a distasteful
"video nasty" and effectively banned for a
decade, not getting released on home video
in uncut form until 1999.
The movie also had a difficult time getting
an uncut release in the United States.
While it was never formally banned, the original
U.S. release was heavily edited, resulting
in a number of different versions being circulated
with dramatic variations.
One version notoriously cut out an astonishing
40 minutes, rearranging scenes and adding
optical effects that turned an already challenging
movie into something all-but-impossible to
understand.
It wasn't until 2000 that the original version
became widely available in the U.S., which
is shocking, considering the movie's relatively
tame nature.
While its plot may feel like a fever dream,
it's no more violent or graphic than other
horror movies of the era.
It's just a lot weirder.
Land of the Dead
Banning a movie instantly makes it more notorious.
Most authorities tend to do it only in extreme
circumstances, with movies so extreme that
they'd test the mettle of even the most jaded
viewer.
So it's odd that a relatively tame studio
effort like George Romero's Land of the Dead
ended up being banned in Ukraine, especially
when more typically-restrictive places like
the U.K. classified the movie as being suitable
for teenagers.
The movie's ban in Ukraine comes down to unique
context; specifically, it was banned for its
portrayal of cannibalism.
Not because its scenes of humans getting devoured
were especially gory, but rather due to concerns
that such content would evoke memories of
the Holodomor, a man-made famine that killed
millions when it was inflicted on the nation
by Joseph Stalin's government between 1932
and '33.
The reason behind the ban raises more questions
than it answers.
Land of the Dead was released in 2005, some
72 years after the events of the genocide,
and doesn't have anything to do with famine
or Soviet history.
You can almost see the rationale, but is a
zombie movie that takes place in post-apocalyptic
Pennsylvania really going to be the thing
that opens those old wounds?
It's one of George Romero's worst movies,
sure, but it's not that bad.
Grotesque
2009's Grotesque is a 73-minute exploitation
horror movie from Japan that focuses chiefly
on the kidnapping and sadistic murder of a
young couple.
That's it.
Nothing else happens.
Grotesque is the dictionary definition of
torture porn.
The U.K.'s film classification board refused
to put any stamp of approval on the film,
stating that the movie actually posed a risk
to society.
Running down the movie's main offenses, the
censors cited acts of "amputation, eye gouging,
castration, and evisceration resulting in
a gory and violent death", in other words,
a typical horror movie fan's definition of
a fun Friday night.
The lack of a traditional narrative only bolstered
the board's decision to reject the movie,
with their assessment being that the film
could not be cut to satisfy their standards
when its very concept was so objectionable.
Grotesque's home country had no such concerns,
although the British ban did spark a debate
over the artistic merits of the splatter film.
The controversy brought a wave of new publicity
to the movie, suggesting once again that there's
nothing so valuable for a movie's long-term
reputation as the allure it gains from being
banned.
Father's Day
Described as "pure grindhouse madness," Father's
Day is a Canadian horror-comedy about a man
getting revenge on the killer who molested
and murdered his father.
The outlandish concept is clearly tongue-in-cheek
in execution, not that that mattered to the
Australian government.
Although Father's Day was allowed to screen
in Sydney for its 2012 theatrical premiere,
classification was refused for its home video
release, resulting in an effective ban on
the movie in the country, with future screenings
of it at film festivals being canceled.
With the film banned from a video release,
a distributor for Father's Day took Australian
censors to task for taking the movie's content
out of context.
After much back-and-forth in the press, the
movie was eventually released in 2013, leaving
a censored version that toned down the gore.
Slender Man
Sony Pictures' Slender Man is the first studio
movie to be inspired by the online horror
phenomenon, telling the story of a group of
teenage girls who seek out the mysterious
monster.
At least, that was the plan.
Prior to its release, Slender Man sparked
controversy due to its relationship to a real-life
attempted murder that took place near Waukesha,
Wisconsin in 2014, when two middle school
students violently attacked their friend in
an effort to appease the fictional creature.
In the lead-up to the movie's theatrical rollout,
the father of one of the attackers condemned
the movie, accusing its producers of capitalizing
on a tragedy, saying,
"In my opinion it's extremely distasteful.
All we're doing is extending the pain all
three of these families have gone through."
Reportedly, the negative buzz spooked Sony
into dramatically chopping down the movie,
removing much of the film's violence, as well
as plot arcs and entire characters.
But for some exhibitors, that self-censorship
wasn't enough, with theaters near the site
of the attack refusing to screen the movie
at all.
The result of all the drama was an incoherent
mess of a movie that got little in the way
of a marketing push, getting poorly-received
by just about everyone.
The most puzzling thing is that anyone could
have seen the controversy coming from a mile
away, which makes one wonder why producers
even tried to make the movie in the first
place.
The Bunny Game
An independent 76-minute movie produced for
$13,000, The Bunny Game easily ran afoul of
British censors upon its release in 2010.
Short, slight, and brutal, the movie centers
on the kidnapping and torture of a prostitute
hitchhiker by a sadistic truck driver, nothing
more, nothing less.
The BBFC refused classification for the movie
on the basis of its graphic depictions of
sexual abuse, calling the movie "unacceptable
to the public."
The board's decision didn't come down to any
one objectionable scene, but rather the movie's
very concept.
According to a statement made by the board,
"The principal focus of the work is the unremitting
sexual and physical abuse of a helpless woman,
as well as the sadistic and sexual pleasure
the man derive[s] from this."
In short, there may be no version of The Bunny
Game that British censors would find acceptable.
On principle alone, that's a pretty big bummer
for British fans of the horror genre.
The Human Centipede 2 (Full Sequence)
Despite its notoriously disgusting concept,
the first Human Centipede movie has a fairly
traditional feel to it.
Its central idea of kidnapped people being
stitched together end-to-end is body horror
more nauseating in concept than in execution,
with the movie itself being fairly restrained
when it comes to graphic detail.
That restraint went out the window for the
movie's sequel, which went to extreme lengths
to shock and horrify, getting itself banned
from several nations upon its release.
Stark and confrontational, The Human Centipede
2 (Full Sequence) hit the throttle on its
use of sadistic, nihilistic violence.
While the first film's villain was a demented
surgeon who at least sort of knew what he
was doing, the second movie's villain is just
demented, creating his centipede with brute
force and barbed wire.
The film is so bleak and brutal that the British
Board of Film Classification outright refused
to give it a rating, saying "no amount of
cuts" would make the movie acceptable enough
to be exhibited or sold.
The movie was eventually approved for release
in the United Kingdom, but only after having
two and a half minutes of footage cut out.
Australia required 30 seconds' worth of edits,
while New Zealand never let the movie screen
at all.
If you missed out on the sequel, you didn't
miss much, but it's still so much better than
the third movie in the series, which censors
around the world didn't even bother with.
That one's not terribly offensive.
It's more just… terrible.